This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人制作。欢迎收听Look Back at it播客。从1979年开始，那对我是个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您正在收听由您喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯为您带来的《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难抉择。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
艾伦女士，你对这份特定的检测进行了两次篡改，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这个节目名字叫TWO percent。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. A subject I'd like to talk about a lot is agency. And the fact that I think in about 80% of instances in our lives, we get to control our reality and what we're experiencing. I think so much about how we operate and how we function, our daily lives is actually within our power. But a lot of us choose to live quite passively. And we let things
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理学。我经常想谈论的一个主题是自主权。事实上，我认为在我们生活中大约80%的情况下，我们能够控制我们的现实以及我们正在经历的事情。我认为我们如何运作、如何运转、我们的日常生活，其实很大程度上都在我们的掌控之中。但我们很多人选择过得相当消极。我们任由事情
happen to us rather than actively choosing who we are, our outlook, our experiences, our behaviors, who we spend time with. We say it all the time on the podcast, but I think sometimes the easiest and most convenient choice is not always the best for you. And this is especially important to recognize in our 20s when we are at such a formative juncture and in the midst of really deciding what we want long term, what we want with our careers, with our health, with our finances. I don't think that we can actually afford to be passive. It doesn't mean that we have to be constantly kind of finding for the next big thing
发生在自己身上，而不是主动选择我们是谁、我们的视角、我们的经历、我们的行为以及我们和谁共度时光。我们在播客中经常说这一点，但我认为有时最简单、最方便的选择并不总是最适合你的。在我们的二十岁时，认清这一点尤为重要，因为我们正处于这样一个形成期的关键节点，正处于真正决定我们长期想要什么、我们的职业生涯、健康和财务想要什么的过程中。我认为我们其实无法承受被动的代价。这并不意味着我们必须不断地去寻找下一个大事
and overworking ourselves. We don't always have to be focused on achievement. but I think more so that we need some kind of structure to how we think about our future, but also about our present and what kind of life we are creating for ourselves. And I thought, who better to bring on for this episode than the wonderful hosts of Girls with Girls to have kind of a discussion and informative conversation on how not to be passive when it comes to creating a happy and fulfilling life. So Carolyn and Catherine, welcome to the show.
并过度透支自己。我们不必总是专注于成就，但我认为更重要的是，我们需要某种结构来思考我们的未来，以及我们的现实，还有我们正在为自己创造什么样的生活。我想，还有谁比“女孩与女孩”（Girls with Girls）的优秀主持人们更适合作为本期节目的嘉宾呢？我们可以进行一场讨论和富有启发性的对话，探讨在创造幸福充实的生活时如何避免被动。所以卡罗琳和凯瑟琳，欢迎来到节目。
Hi, thank you so much for having us. Caroline. I'm in Catherine. We are, we're twin sisters. We're based in Boston in the U.S. and we host the show Girls with Goals. We talk so much on our show about health and wellness, but mostly in the sense of how it fits into our lifestyles and ultimately building your own most confident life, however that's going to look. And, you know, every topic we dive into is something that we're actively navigating at the same time. And I think figuring out how to have that right balance of control over your lives while at the same time being kind of trusting in the path and not trying to get too overwhelmed with the control is something that we're always working
嗨，非常感谢邀请我们。卡罗琳。我是凯瑟琳。我们是双胞胎姐妹。我们总部设在美国波士顿，我们主持节目《目标女孩》（Girls with Goals）。我们在节目中经常谈论健康和养生，但主要是关于它如何融入我们的生活方式，并最终建立你最自信的生活，无论它看起来是什么样的。而且，你知道，我们深入探讨的每一个话题都是我们同时在积极应对的事情。我认为，弄清楚如何对生活保持适度的掌控感，同时又能信任这条道路，不被这种控制欲弄得不知所措，是我们一直在努力解决的问题。
to figure out. So I think hopefully we'll be able to come and bring some good advice on how to stop being passive in your life and take more control without it being too overwhelming of a feat to take on. Yeah, I love the word control in a good way is what we're getting at here. controls and you're in the power of your life, which I think is really important when we're talking about whether or not you're living passively. So we love, you know, like Caroline said, this is a time that we're navigating actively ourselves and that's what we talk about. So, you know, we're working on trying not to be passive or being aware of that and knowing how to be confident within that and, you know, actively work towards moving away from passive life and taking more control and feeling empowered in our lives is what we talk about. all the time. So this is a really great episode. Thank you so much for having us. Absolutely. Well, I feel like that's something I really admire about you guys. Firstly, you're in your 20s, which I think is like, obviously the psychology of your 20s. Like I like talking to people who also kind of get it. But I really admire how you're both like quite intentional in how you live, right? You really like
所以我想，希望我们能带来一些好的建议，教大家如何停止在生活中表现得消极，并在不让自己感到不堪重负的情况下获得更多控制权。是的，我喜欢“控制”这个词，这里我们指的是一种积极的控制。掌控并掌握你生活的力量，我认为这在我们讨论你是否在消极生活时非常重要。所以我们喜欢，就像卡罗琳说的，这是一个我们自己正在积极应对的阶段，这也是我们所谈论的。所以，你知道，我们正在努力不被动，或者意识到这一点，并知道如何在其中保持自信，你知道，积极努力摆脱消极的生活，掌控更多，并在我们的生活中感到充满力量，这是我们一直在谈论的。所以这是一个非常棒的节目。非常感谢你们邀请我们。绝对的。嗯，我觉得这是我真正佩服你们的地方。首先，你们才二十岁，我觉得这就像，很明显是二十岁的心理学。就像我喜欢和那些也能理解这一点的人交谈。但我真的很佩服你们两个在生活方式上都相当有主见，对吧？你们真的很
prioritize the good parts of life as much as you can, even when it's difficult. Like you guys are full-time students. You're running your own businesses. When it comes to, to that what do you think it means to be intentional, especially when we have like so many other things on our plate that can make it really difficult to focus on bringing, like, I feel like being intentional sometimes gets compared to putting in more effort, right, and having to give more energy when you don't actually have it. But what does it mean for you guys? Yeah, it's definitely not just straight up putting in more energy. And I think we've all been there where that is our default, because it's the simplest, seemingly simplest solution before you actually, you know, try out some
尽可能地优先享受生活中的美好部分，即使在困难的时候也是如此。就像你们是全职学生。你们在经营自己的生意。当谈到这一点时，你认为有主见意味着什么，尤其是当我们有很多其他事情要处理，这使得我们很难专注于带来——我觉得有主见有时会被比作付出更多的努力，对吧，在没有真正精力的时侯不得不付出更多的能量。但对你们来说这意味着什么呢？是的，这绝对不仅仅是直接投入更多的能量。我想我们都经历过这种情况，那是我们的默认选择，因为它是最简单的，表面上最简单的解决方案，在你真正去尝试一些
solutions. It's kind of our default, our go-to. Just if things aren't working out or they're not working out as you want them to, just throw more effort in, like do more things, work harder. Not the answer all the time, because that almost pushes you further into that, you know, passiveness. Anytime I felt like I'm in a state of passiveness, passiveness. First of all, I don't realize it until like a month or two or, or, you know, you. even more down the line. And I'm like, oh my God, I've been living on autopilot. Like, I couldn't even tell you what happened these past four months. But having the, you know, ability to acknowledge that and pull yourself out of that is a really intentional thing. And it's not to say that you're never
解决方案之前。这有点像是我们的默认设置，我们的首选。如果事情没有按预期发展，或者没有按照你希望的那样发展，那就投入更多的努力，比如做更多的事情，更努力地工作。这并不总是答案，因为那几乎会把你进一步推向那种，你知道的，被动。每当我觉得自己处于一种被动状态时，被动状态。首先，我直到一个月或两个月，或者，你知道，更久之后才意识到。然后我想，天哪，我一直在自动驾驶状态下生活。比如，我甚至说不出这过去四个月发生了什么。但是拥有，你知道，承认这一点并把自己拉出来的能力，是一件非常刻意的事情。这并不是说你永远
going to have times of feeling passive or, you know, that you have to throw yourself an autopilot. But when you do notice it, being able to, you know, pull yourself out of it. And sometimes that means not throwing more more gas on the fire, but taking a step back and going back to those foundations. And so knowing that there are a bunch of different options and that maybe not putting all your effort in and losing all of your steam and absolutely burning out is the best answer. Sometimes it's taking a step back and going back to your, you know, foundations, the things that you absolutely have to do. Yeah, I totally agree. I read this article actually like today by the Atlantic called like the status of being business.
不会感到被动，或者说你必须让自己陷入自动驾驶状态。但是当你注意到它的时候，能够，你知道，把自己拉出来。有时这意味着不要往火上浇油，而是退后一步，回到那些基础。所以，知道有很多不同的选择，也许不把所有的努力都投进去，失去所有的动力并彻底精疲力竭并不是最好的答案。有时是退后一步，回到你的，你知道的，基础，你绝对必须要做的事情。是的，我完全同意。我其实今天读了《大西洋月刊》的一篇文章，叫做忙碌的状态。
which is that like in this day and age, being busy is seen as like as being successful, as being popular as being like a go getter when actually busyness really just demonstrates. Yes, obviously like a period of just having a lot on and chaos. But actually it represents an inability to set personal boundaries in a way because you don't and you haven't been intentional in putting time aside, right? I think you made a really good point. Like we talk about not being passive. Not being passive doesn't mean being active, right?
也就是说，在当今时代，忙碌被视为成功、受欢迎、积极进取的象征，而实际上忙碌恰恰证明了。是的，显然是一个事情很多且混乱的时期。但实际上它代表了一种无法设定个人边界的表现，因为你没有，而且你一直没有刻意留出时间，对吧？我觉得你提出了一个很好的观点。就像我们谈论不被动一样。不被动并不意味着一直处于活跃状态，对吧？
Like you would think that that's the opposite, right? Okay, if I don't want to be passive, I better be doing things all the time. But it's actually being intentional. It's actually being like, okay, wait, is this really, I think I really liked the example of you being like, okay, feeling the need to spend every single night with friends, feeling need to go out, to go out to dinner. that is the easiest thing because saying yes is the easiest thing but saying no is the hard thing and it's sometimes the right thing. So how do you think we can shift our outlook and our behaviors to be more intentional? What do you think like kind of being in the passenger, being in like the driver's seat, not the passenger seat, really like means in our 20s?
就像你会认为那是对立面一样，对吧？好吧，如果我不想被动，我最好一直做事情。但实际上这是有主见的。实际上是这样的，好吧，等等，这真的是，我觉得我真的很喜欢你的那个例子，就是，好吧，觉得有必要每天晚上都和朋友在一起，觉得有必要出去，出去吃晚饭。那是做起来最容易的事，因为说“好”是最容易的事，但说“不”才是困难的事，而有时这才是正确的事。所以你认为我们该如何转变我们的视角和行为，变得更有主见？在我们的二十岁，处于驾驶座上而不是乘客座位上，到底意味着什么？
Yeah. Ironically, some of the times that I felt most passive in my life have also been times where I'm most busy because I am filling my plate with all of these things while I'm being avoidant to maybe more of the personal goals and the personal things that are actually going to fulfill me. Business does not always equal fulfillment. And sometimes I think the hardest thing is to slow down, be honest with yourself, spend time just with yourself and like doing those slower things and figuring out kind of what your next step is and deciding what step to take forward rather than being so busy that you can
是的。具有讽刺意味的是，我生活中感觉最被动的某些时刻，也恰恰是我最忙碌的时刻，因为我把这些事情塞满了我的日程，以此来逃避那些可能更能真正让我感到充实的个人目标和个人事务。忙碌并不总是等于充实。有时我认为最难的事情是慢下来，对自己诚实，花时间独自一人，做那些比较慢的事情，弄清楚你的下一步是什么，并决定迈出哪一步，而不是忙得连
even make that choice, you're just always moving. Sometimes for me, that that busyness actually is the passiveness because I'm being avoidant to my own life. And so I think the first thing that I would do if you find yourself being passive is to try to figure out why that is happening. Is it fear of not being able to reach a goal that you have in your mind? Is it a lack of self-confidence to spend time with yourself and to step up because maybe you've never been very comfortable just being alone with yourself and being accepting of yourself and working on yourself. Or maybe it's even just being kind of overwhelmed and unsure of which direction to go because especially in our 20s when nobody has their lives figured out at all and we see all of these people around us in our own lives and then
那个选择都做不出，你只是总在向前。有时对我来说，这种忙碌实际上就是被动，因为我在逃避我自己的生活。所以我想如果你发现自己很被动，我要做的第一件事就是试着找出这背后的原因。是对无法实现心中目标的恐惧吗？是对花时间独处和挺身而出的自信心不足吗，也许是因为你从来不太习惯独自一人并接受自己、提升自己？或者也许只是感到不知所措，不确定该往哪个方向走，因为尤其是在我们的二十岁，没有人真正把生活搞清楚，我们看到周围生活中的所有人，然后
also perpetuated on the internet going in all different directions all at once. It can be really overwhelming to decide which direction we even want to go in. And then how do we even take that first step forward if there's a hundred options and we don't know which one to do? So being able to take that step back first rather than filling our lives with more busyness and see why am I being passive? Is it fear? Is it self-confidence? Is it that I'm overwhelmed? And then what is that first step forward for myself that's actually going to work? Not just what everyone else is doing. And I think that comes down to values, right? That is such a precious and like personal thing for each of us. But when we're really caught up in comparing ourselves, that's a big one,
也在互联网的推波助澜下，朝着各种不同的方向同时前进。要决定我们到底想朝哪个方向前进，可能会让人不知所措。如果有成百上千个选择而我们不知道该选哪个，我们又该如何迈出那第一步呢？所以，与其用更多的忙碌填满我们的生活，不如先退一步，看看我为什么会被动？是恐惧吗？是自信心吗？是因为我不知所措吗？然后，对我来说，什么才是真正行之有效的第一步？而不仅仅是盲目效仿别人的做法。我认为这归结于价值观，对吧？这对我们每个人来说都是如此珍贵和私人的东西。但是当我们真正陷入相互比较时，这是一个大问题，
seeing what everyone else is doing and feeling like we're coming up short. your motivation is not the same as theirs. You have no idea why they're doing what they're doing, why it's important to them, their stamina, their energy reserves, whether they're actually sitting back at the end of the day and being like, wow, nothing I did today was intentional. This was all just like clutter that I felt compelled to do. So I think taking time to be like, okay, I don't actually need to know what I want exactly. I don't need a five-year plan.
看到别人在做什么，觉得自己有所欠缺。你的动力和他们不一样。你根本不知道他们为什么要做他们正在做的事，为什么这对他们重要，他们的耐力如何，他们的能量储备如何，他们是否真的在一天结束时坐在那里想，哇，我今天做的事没有一件是有主见的。这全都是我出于某种强迫感而去做的心灵杂物。所以我想花点时间去想，好吧，我其实不需要确切地知道自己想要什么。我不需要一个五年计划。
I don't need to have it all worked out. I think having it all worked out is actually a bad thing because you have no room for flexibility and for surprise and for excitement. It's mainly being like, what are the values that I want to guide my decision making by? Is it that I want to be like guided by creativity and I want to be exploring ways to be creative? And that means that no, I can't say yes to all my social plans because I do need space for rest and space for my imagination. Is it, okay, I'm really motivated by growth and I'm really motivated by intelligence or I'm really motivated by whatever it is that is like, oh, I think independence.
我不需要把一切都规划好。我认为把一切都规划好其实是一件坏事，因为这样你就没有了灵活性、惊喜和兴奋的空间。这主要是指：我希望什么价值观来指导我的决策？是我希望以创造力为导向，并探索富有创造力的方法吗？这意味着不，我不能对所有的社交计划都说“好”，因为我确实需要休息的空间和想象力的空间。是吗？好吧，我真的被成长所驱动，我真的被智慧所驱动，或者我真的被任何让我觉得“哦，我觉得是独立”的东西所驱动。
Maybe that's like the value that drives your kind of financial goals and how active you are and your financial goals, right? It's like stop trying to pursue things from a place of wanting to please others or wanting to do what others are doing. That's what makes you passive. Do it from a place of once again when you're intentional about your motivations, your inspiration, your mission, I think everything becomes a lot easier. Have you guys kind of found that? Exactly. Something that has always grounded me in my own life because it can definitely be
也许这就像是驱动你的财务目标以及你在财务目标上有多积极的价值观，对吧？这就好比不要再试图从取悦他人或随波逐流的角度去追求事物。那只会让你变得被动。如果你能再次以明确的动机、灵感和使命感出发，我认为一切都会变得容易得多。你们大家有这种感觉吗？确实如此。在我的生活中，总有一些东西能让我保持脚踏实地，因为去思考诸如“五年后我想成为什么样的人？我的具体职业会是什么？”这样的大问题，对我和我来说绝对是让人感到不堪重负的。因为对我而言，选定一条路从来都不是一件顺理成章的事。但真正能让我脚踏实地、让我更稳定、在生活中更积极的，是不去管那些，而是去想，好吧，我并不确切知道我需要什么具体的东西。我不需要确切知道那个职业等等方面的具体道路、人际关系和时间表。我不需要知道这些。但对真正重要的事情是去了解，比如，我那些永远不会改变的价值观是什么，以及我对生活的期待是怎样的感觉。因为在二十多岁的时候——我作为一个刚刚跨入二十多岁的人这么说，我才21岁，但我认为这是一个非常好的
overwhelming for me to think about like, where do I want to see myself in five years? What do I want my exact career to be? Because for me, that's never been something that has come naturally, picking one path. But what really grounds me and helps me be more stable and be more active in my life regardless of that is to think about, okay, I don't know exactly what the tangible thing is that I need. I don't need to know exactly the tangible path in that career and whatever, the relationship and the timeline. I don't need to know that. But what really matters to me is to know, like, what my values are that are always going to be there and what the feeling that I want in life is. Because your 20s, and I say this as someone who just basically started my 20s, I'm only 21, but I think it's such a good
时期去尝试，因为没有人确切知道自己要走向何方。就像你说的，我觉得你也不应该知道。我觉得这其实是一件不太好的事，因为你会把自己限制在一条路上，不允许自己改变主意，或者不让自己对可能出现的其他机会保持开放的态度。因此，当我试图关注我从生活中渴望获得的那种感觉，而不是那些具象的事物时，我真的能够对出现的机遇以及所有可能带给我这种感觉的事物保持开放心态。所以，举个例子，如果我们谈论的是那种独立和自由的感觉，你可以在生活中通过宏大或微小的各种方式在日常中找到它。所以也许这种财务独立，或者仅仅是
time to experiment because nobody knows exactly where they're going. And like you said, I don't think you should. I think that's kind of a bad thing because you're going to put yourself on a path and you're not going to let yourself change your mind or you're not going to keep yourself open to other opportunities that might come up. And so when I try to focus on the feeling that I want out of my life instead of those tangible things, I can really keep myself open to opportunities that come up and all of these things that might bring those feelings for me. So, for example, if we're talking about that feeling of independence and freedom, you can find different ways to get that out of your life on big levels and on little levels throughout your day. So maybe that financial independence or just
那种宏大构想中的整体自由感，就是拥有自己的生意并为自己打工。但也许这并不是你当下触手可及的具体事情，但你仍然想要拥有那种感觉。所以也许低一个层面的做法是去旅行，或者读读书，去了解你感兴趣的事物并从中获得掌控感和独立感。甚至在日常生活中，仅仅是独自完成一些活动。因此，当你清楚自己的价值观和真实感受时，我认为这有助于你从第一天起就积极地投入生活，因为它不需要是“我现在就要直奔终点线”。而是有些事情我可以
that feeling of freedom in general on the grandest scheme you can think of is owning your own business and working for yourself. But maybe that's not a tangible, reachable thing for you in this moment, but you still want to have that feeling. So maybe a lower level of that, is doing some traveling or maybe reading books and just educating yourself on things that you're interested in and taking that sense of agency and independence in your life. And maybe even on a day-to-day level, it's just doing activities by yourself. So when you know what those values are and what those feelings are, I think that it helps you to be active in your life from day one because it doesn't need to be. I'm jumping right to the finish line right now. But there are things that I can find
在今天、这周、这个月找到，它们依然能带给我那种感觉，然后事情就会像滚雪球一样不断发展。有时这听起来有点傻。我们的节目名叫《有目标的女孩》（Girls with Goals），但在最近——我是说，我们做这个节目快三年了——在最近，我想说是两年里，对于“你的目标是什么？你的人生想做什么？”这个问题，我们的回答是：感觉。我们其实没有什么答案。就像，我们只想追求不断完善和感觉良好。我不认为这是我们在三年前刚开播时会给出的答案。我当时可能会给你列出一份我想实现的五个目标的清单。而且，你知道，也许我真的实现了那五个目标，但当你实现它们之后，生活并不会停止。
today this week, this month that still give me that feeling and things can really snowball from there. Sometimes it's kind of silly. Our show name is Girls with Goals, but in the recent, I mean, we've been doing this for almost three years. And the recent, I'd say, two years, our answer to the question, like, what are your goals? What do you want to do with your life? Are feelings. We don't really have an answer. Like, we just want to chase improvement and chase feeling good. and that is, I don't think it's the answer that we would have said three years ago when we started this show. I probably would have given you a list of like five things that I want to accomplish. And, you know, maybe I did accomplish those five things, but it doesn't stop when you accomplish them.
如果生活没有达成目标，或者你在路上经历了一些失败，生活也不会停止。因此，我认为我们在过去几年里学到了一个非常非常重要的一点，这也是我们不得不一遍又一遍去表达的概念，即关于目标的定义，在我们的思维框架中，我们没有目标，或者至少不一定是具象的目标，但我们确实有方向。我们对自身有一种期待的品质。我认为这是一个非常重大的转折，它带领我——我是说我自己，至少引领我走向了一个更有控制力、更有意识、真正充满自我觉察的成长与完善之旅，无论那意味着生活的方方面面。所以我没法告诉你，我每天都去健身房。我不会坐在这里告诉你我有
And life also doesn't stop if you don't accomplish your goals or if you have some failures along the way. And so I think a massive, massive point that we've learned in the past couple years that this has been something that we've, you know, had to articulate over and over again, the concept of goals. and in our frame of mind, what are our goals, are that we don't have any, or at least not tangible ones necessarily, but we do have a direction. We have a kind of quality that we expect of ourselves. And I think that is a really big point that's taken us, I mean, I'm speaking for myself, but taking me at least into a more, you know, controlled and intentional and like really self-aware journey into improvement and whatever that may be, literally every aspect of life. So I can't tell you, I go to the gym every day. I'm not going to sit here and tell you I have
一个健身目标，因为我无法向你保证。我不想这么做。这是一个持续的过程。完全正确。我的意思是，三年前，我还觉得“我要深蹲达到150磅”。我甚至不知道我现在的深蹲重量是多少。没错。而且我也说不出我现在的深蹲重量。我去健身房是因为我想持续向自己兑现承诺，我想感觉自己很强壮，我想保持健康。这就是我这样做的原因。当然，生活中会有各种各样的事情发生。在一路上设立各种各样的小目标其实很有趣，但这并不是终极目标。有时，当你设定了那些非常具体、非常具象的目标时，你就会感觉到被动感悄然而至，因为
a gym goal because I couldn't tell you that. I don't want to. It's a continuous thing. Exactly. And I mean, three years ago, I was like, I want to hit 150 pounds squat. I don't know what my squat weight is. Right. And I couldn't tell you how much I squat right now. I would go to the gym because I want to continue showing up for myself and I want to feel strong and I want to be healthy. And like, that's why I do it. And of course, things come in and now. You have different mini goals in your life. And it's really fun to set many goals along the way, but that's not like the end-all be-all goal. And sometimes when you do set those really tangible and really specific goals, that's when you feel the passiveness come in because
那正是你为之奋斗的全部。你的视野变得狭隘，只盯着那个目标。而其他所有事情都被抛在脑后，或者被抛诸脑后。你并没有真正为之付出有意识的努力。然后你会陷入一种死胡同，事情开始变得杂乱无章。我很喜欢你刚才说的那句话，甚至连你正在努力实现的目标都开始让人觉得有点杂乱。然后你会到达一个真正的临界点，心想：我到底在干什么？我的意思是，到了那个时候，你正处于被动状态，我猜，你正在从中挣脱出来。
that's all you're working towards. Your kind of tunnel vision towards that. And everything else falls behind or is in front of mind. You're not really putting an intentional effort towards it. And then you get into this rut where things feel so much like clutter. I'd love that word that you said earlier, that even the goal you're working towards feels a little bit like clutter. And then you're going to get to a point really, what am I even doing? And I mean, at that point, you're in the passive era and you're, I guess, snapping out of it.
但这正是你如何……在我的脑海里，以我的经验来看，我是如何变得被动的——几乎是因为对想要的事务变得过于具体，达到了一种让人不堪重负的程度。这其实太有趣了，因为我的问题之一本来是：随着年龄的增长，你与目标的关系发生了怎样的变化？哦，哇。当时我想：这真是一个极好的回答。是的，这绝对也关乎成熟度。
But that's how you kind of, in my mind, that's in my experience, how I've become passive is almost by getting too specific on what I want in an overwhelming sense. That's actually so interesting because one of my questions was going to be, how is your relationship to your goals changed as you get older? Oh, wow. And I was like, that's like such a good answer. Yeah. That definitely is like a maturity thing too.
我的意思是，我知道你是苏（So）迷。我知道卡罗尔有《Hair So Can》。但是——拜口误，如果我歌词记错了请狠狠地冲我喊。18岁时觉得无所不知，21岁时却又一无所知？哦，对。没错，就是这样。我觉得这就是。谢谢大家。嗯，我的意思是，这显然是很多人都能感同身受的事情。你会有那种“自己无所不知”的感觉。也许当你18岁左右时，那些非常具体的目标确实管用，因为你不需要马上付诸行动。或者你只是有个梦想。如果你真的去付诸行动，就像卡洛琳所说的那样，那并不是“我要拥有自己的
I mean, I know you're a so fan. I know Carol has hair so can. But the like, please, please yell at me if I get the lyrics wrong. 18 and nothing at, how do you know everything at 18 and nothing at 21? Oh yeah. That was right. That's, I feel like that. That's, that's being. Thanks guys. Um, I mean, that's obviously something that a lot of people can relate to. You kind of feel like you have everything. And maybe those really specific goals work well when you're around 18 because you're, you don't have to act on them right on them right away. Or have a dream. And if you do act on them, like Caroline said, it's not, I'm going to own my own
公司”，而是“我去上班。我在高中打最低工资的工，这就是我所理解的财务自由”。这大概满足了那种渴望。然而一旦到了21岁，是的，风险要低得多，它是呈指数级增长的，而在几年之后，你到了21岁，就会发现世界充满了无限可能。是的，我认为我与目标设定的关系在最近几年发生的变化是，我的很多目标更多是这种持续性的目标，而不是终局目标。因为在我的脑海里，以及我的思维运作方式中，我是非常具有未来导向和前瞻性的。如果我告诉自己我需要什么、想要做什么，我就会变得如此一门心思，以至于它往往会把我引向一条焦虑的道路，必须以最快的速度到达
business, it's like, I go to work. I work my minimum wage job in high school, and that's me with financial freedom. Like, that satisfies that craving, I guess. Whereas once you're 21, yeah, the stakes are much lower, it's exponential, whereas a few years later, you're 21, world of possibilities. Yeah, I think how my relationship with goal setting has changed in the more recent years is that a lot of my goals are more of these continuous goals. versus end game goals because it in for my mind and the way that my mind works I am very future and forward thinking and if I tell myself that I need something and want to do something I get so one track minded with it that it tends to lead me down this like anxious path of having to get
某个地方，沿着那条轨道前进，然后我就会非常排斥身边的其他事情。显然，当事情没有完全如愿时，这就不是件好事。我认为有一件事真正向我证明了我确实成熟了，并且最近在这方面做得很好：当时我在寻找兼职实习以及在未来一年中可以做的事情，因为我大学还剩一年，但实际上我只需要上一学期的课。所以我的日程安排轻松很多，当时我想，好吧，也许我想去波士顿的一家初创公司工作，以此来填补更多的时间。我对这样一个机会感到非常兴奋。那是市场营销相关的工作，涉及体育营销，感觉非常符合我的兴趣，
somewhere as fast as I can and like on that track and then I'm pretty avoidant of other things around me and then obviously that is not good when you don't get exactly there. And I think something that really showed me that I actually have matured and that I've done that well recently is I was looking for part-time internships and things to do with this next year ahead of me because I have one year of college left, but I actually only have one semester worth of classes to do. So I have a much lower schedule and I was like, okay, well, maybe I want to work for a startup in Boston and kind of fill more of my time. And I was really excited about this one opportunity. It was like sports marketing, seemed really up my alley,
你知道，其中包含一些社交媒体、健身和市场营销的元素。我在这家公司经历了一个月、三轮面试，结果他们把我拒绝了。这确实……挺难过的。但说实话，我很震惊自己竟然能走到那一步，当时我想：哈，好吧，那这肯定不是我该做的事。如果换作几年前的我，在被拒绝了一件我多少投入了感情并开始憧憬未来的事情之后，我可能会深受打击。而这一次，我能够在一之内就向前看并把它抛诸脑后，因为我有播客在做，而且我还有学业。我知道其他机会还会出现并向我敞开。因此，我认为能够拥有更多这种持续性的目标，比如“我只想感到自己是成功的、独立的、健康的”，而不是“我必须通过在确切的时间得到这个确切的职位来感到自己是成功的”，这真的能推动我不断前进，因为我认为在后来的
you know, had some social media aspects and fitness and marketing. And I was one month, three interviews deep in this company, and they turned me down. And which, yeah, sad. But honestly, I was so shocked that I got that. And I was like, huh, okay, well, it must not be what I was supposed to be doing. And, like, myself a couple years ago, having been rejected to something that I was, you know, a little bit emotionally involved in and, like, starting to think forward about it. I would have been so much more destroyed by that, whereas I was able to, like, move on and forget about it than a day because I have my podcast going for me and I still have school. And I know that other opportunities are going to come and open up. And so I think that being able to have more of these continuous goals of like, I just want to feel successful. I want to feel independent. I want to feel healthy versus I want to feel successful by getting this exact position at this exact time really keeps me moving forward because I think that in late.
岁月里，如果我曾经被拒绝或遭遇挫折，我可能就会直接停在原地、陷入僵局，而不会继续前行了。所以，特别是在你二十多岁正在摸索这些人生道路时，如果你能带着“不需要它们成为终局”的压力去着手做事情，那么前行的道路就会变得更加令人兴奋，你能够在这一过程中去学习、进化和成长，而不是把某件事视为死胡同。我认为那种过于具象、过于具体、在当下几乎遥不可及的大目标——因为我绝不会说没有什么事情是
later years, if I had gotten rejected or something, then I might have just stopped and stalled right there, and I wouldn't have kept moving forward. And so I think specifically in your 20s, when you're navigating these paths and like, what am I going to do? If you can set out to do things without the pressure of them having to be end game, then taking that path forward is so much more exciting and you're able to learn and evolve and grow along the way rather than, you know, seeing something as a hard stop. And I think that kind of the really tangible, really specific big goals that are almost too far out of reach in the current moment, because I will never tell you that nothing is
遥不可及的。但在当下，如果你设定了一个巨大无比的目标，那它可能就是遥不可及的。这种目标如何让人变得被动呢？我一边听卡洛琳讲话，一边在脑海中整理着这个概念。当你设定了那些非常非常大的目标时，我知道它们为什么对我不奏效，我也知道很多人可能都有过同样的体验，那就是你几乎在自我怀疑，
too far out of reach. But in the current moment, something is probably too far out of reach if you're setting a massive, massive goal. The way that that becomes passive, I think just listening to Caroline Talk, this is my concept on it, is what my brain's doing. while I'm listening to her. When you get those really, really big goals, the reason I know they don't work out for me and I know a lot of people probably have the same experience is you're almost doubting yourself
而自我怀疑是我们经常讨论的话题，或者反过来说是自信。因为我们当然想要自信，如果自我怀疑过于消极的话，我们其实并不想要它。但在被动意义上，自我怀疑是具有破坏性的。所以当你设定这些非常非常大的目标时，就好像你会自我设障，我确信你们以前在节目上也讨论过这一点。但你会自我设障，在我看来，退回到被动状态百分之百就是那种自我设障。因为你会想：我甚至都不会去尝试。我只是会在心底暗暗希望这个我自以为想要的宏大目标能够实现。
and self-doubt is something that we talk about a lot or the inverse self-confidence. Because we want self-confidence, of course, don't really want self-doubt if it's debilitating. But in the passive sense, self-doubt is debilitating. And so when you set these really, really big goals, it's like, You kind of self-sabotage, and I'm sure you've talked about this on your show before, too. But you kind of self-sabotage, and that default into the passive zone is, in my mind, 100% that self-sabotage. Because you're like, kind of I'm not even going to try. I'm just going to, in the back of my mind, hope that this massive goal that I think I want for myself works out.
但我其实并不会为之付出海量的努力，或者说是有意识的努力。这不是我们想要呆的区域。这会让你觉得时间还很充裕，对吧？因为这是一个如此重大的宏愿。但我也觉得……这为借口留下了巨大的空间。没错。我还认为，对于像数字那样的大目标，例如，你刚才提到的深蹲150磅，或者我不知道，某一个巨大的里程碑，比如马拉松。这也是其中之一。诸如此类的事情。这就好比，一旦你达到了那个目标，你就会失去动力。因为这不具备可持续性，因为你的目标只是时间线上的一个点。它存在于你达成目标之前，存在于你达成目标的那一刻，而达成之后你便一无所有。我当时正在和我的朋友聊天，
But I'm really not going to put, like, tons of effort towards it or, like, intentional effort. And that's not a zone that we want to be in. it feels like you have so much time, right? Because it is such a big thing. But I also think that... So much space for excuses. Exactly. I also think that like with big goals that are like numbers. For example, you talked about like 150 pounds squat or like, I don't know, a huge milestone, a marathon. That's another one. Something like that. It's like, okay, once you hit that, you lose steam. Because it's not sustainable because your goal is one point in time. It is before you reach the goal and it is when you reach the goal and the after is you don't have anything for that. And I was talking to my friend
她最近刚跑完马拉松。太令人佩服了。她说：“我再也不想跑步了，因为那简直太折腾人了。”她说那太糟糕了。她当时正在……她基本上围绕着这个她以为会给自己带来很多其他东西的宏大目标，重塑了她整个的生活方式。她以为这会带给她自信，带给她掌控感，带给她赋权。是的，这些事情确实发生了。但她并没有去考虑跑步如何能将这些东西作为一种生活方式去促进，她只想着自己要如何达成这个目标。这意味着一旦目标达成，所有的习惯、所有的过程、
who did a marathon recently. So impressive. And she was like, yeah, I don't want to run anymore because that was so freaking exhausting. She was like, that was awful. Like I'm, I was working. She basically recreated her whole lifestyle around this huge thing that she, I think thought was going to bring her a lot of other things. It was going to bring her confidence. It was going to bring her control. It was going to bring her empowerment. Yes, those things did happen. But she was, wasn't thinking about how running was going to promote those things as a lifestyle. She was thinking about how she was going to get to this goal. And what that meant was that once the goal had been obtained, all of the habits, all of
以及她在那个过程中所有的心态调整，突然之间（你知道的）对她都不再有用了。所以我认为，当我们在思考目标、思考如何在生活中保持积极、不做被动的主体时，这其实是一个非常重要的部分。你的脑海里可能会立刻闪过：好吧，我需要设定一个尽可能大的目标，因为这会给我带来专注。但实际上，一旦目标达成，你的时间也就到头了，你并没有去思考如何围绕这件事以及超越这件事去真正创造一种美好的生活——如果这样说得通的话。是的，这太合情合理了。我很喜欢这个观点。
the processes, all of the attitude adjustments that she'd had in that process were suddenly, you know, no longer useful for her. And so I think that that's like a really important part about when we think about goals and you think about being being active in your life, not being a passive agent, immediately your mind might go to, okay, well, I need to set like the biggest goal possible because that's going to give me focus. But really, your time kind of ends when that goal is reached and you're not thinking about how you actually want to create a good life around that thing and beyond that thing, if that makes sense. Yeah, that makes so much sense. I love that.
是的。因为你实际上缩短了你的生命。你不再用长远的眼光去思考人生，比如“我会活到很久很久以后，跑步会让我保持健康、锻炼肌肉、增强骨密度、促进心肺功能。这会帮助我活得更久，让我有大把的时间去享受生活、体验那么多新鲜事物”。相反，你会变成：“哦，我的马拉松在六个月后，我的生活现在在我的脑海里只剩下这六个月了。”然后其他任何事情对你来说都不再重要，或者说没有哪件事能占据你大脑的前沿。不再是（你知道的）职业的可持续发展、极力维系深厚的友谊。除了那个马拉松训练的例子之外，其他超越它的所有事情都落入了被动区。
Yeah. Because you kind of shorten your life. You stop thinking about your life in terms of like I'm going to live till forever and me running is going to make me healthy and like get my muscles up and build my bone strength and get my heart pumping. And that's going to help me live forever and like have so much time to enjoy life and experience so many new things. Like oh my marathons in six months like my life now only exists six months out in my head. And then nothing else is really important to you anymore or nothing else is at the forefront of your brain. It's not, you know, career longevity, maintaining friendships super heavily. Anything else beyond just that marathon training example falls into the passive zone.
是的。你知道，这其实非常有趣，因为我以前从未想过有人会有这样的经历。你知道，你很少看到人们讨论达成这样伟大目标后的余波，但你在商界却经常看到这种情况——某个人异军突起获得了巨大成功，然后突然之间第二天就破产了。你会想：天哪，怎么会发生这种事？这或许是因为我们没有为长寿和可持续性做好规划，所以并不是说不要去设定马拉松之类的大目标，而是或许应该把它变成一段更长、更慢的旅程，通过脚踏实地的小步骤去达成，或者提前规划好：好吧，事后我该如何继续保持这种状态，而不是把它变成
Yeah. You know, that's actually very interesting because I had never thought about somebody having that experience. You know, you don't see people talking about kind of the aftermath of achieving great goals like that, but you do see it so often in, you know, business where somebody it takes off and is so successful and then all of a sudden there's bankruptcy the next day and it's like oh my god how did that happen and it's maybe because we're not planning for longevity and sustainability and so not to say don't go out and set the big goals of the marathon and things like that but maybe make it a longer journey and take the baby steps to get there or plan ahead for like okay how do i want to continue to do this after the fact instead of making it
那种终局。也许在生活中采取更多行动，意味着要提前思考事后我该如何去管理这一切，从而避免在事后重新陷入被动状态。因为目标很重要。这就是……我感觉，很显然我们坐在这里会觉得：不，目标超级重要。它们太有价值了。就像昨晚，我还写日记记录这些，心想：这就是我对未来六个月生活的期望。但我想要的东西并不是那么具体。我觉得有一种所谓的“SMART原则”目标，它们必须是具体的、可衡量的、可操作的、符合实际且有时效性的。是的，那很好。
kind of that end game. Maybe it, maybe that taking more action in your life is thinking ahead towards how am I going to manage this afterwards and not fall back into a passive state after. Because goals are important. Like that's the, I feel like, obviously like we're sitting here being like, no, goals are super important. They are so valuable. Like even last night, I was journaling about it and being like, this is what I want out of the next six months of my life. But the things that I wanted were not like specific. They weren't like, I feel like there's this thing of like smart goals where they have to be like specific, measurable, actionable, something are realistic and timely. Yeah, that's great.
但我的意思是，有时候能够拥有那种宏观的、能够随着你不断演进的方向，才是我真正觉得在我的生活中改变了游戏规则的东西。太棒了。谢谢你们的分享。这真是太棒了。
Love that. But, and I get that there's like a lot of research behind that. I really actually don't agree. Yeah, I get that it's like a really nice idea, but I'm like, actually no. Those are things that once you do, you tick them off and you actually aren't invested in as a lifestyle change. Yes. Whereas when you have goals that are like personal, sustainable and like about attitudes and beliefs and lifestyle, like those things are so much more valuable for actually changing your life.
我非常认同这一点。但是——我知道背后有很多研究支持——其实我真的不太赞同。对，我明白这听起来是个很好的主意，但我的反应其实是：不对。有些事情一旦你做了，你就在清单上打勾了，而你其实并没有真正投入其中作为一种生活方式的改变。对。而当你设定那些关乎个人、可持续、以及关于态度、信念和生活方式的目标时，这些东西对真正改变你的生活才有价值得多。
And I was listening to this TED talk, which I love. It's the Elizabeth Gilbert one on like success. And she basically said that all her life she had been, she's an author. She'd been waiting for success. and she'd been waiting for a book to be published and for a book to become a bestseller. And then she wrote a pre-love, which everybody knows, cultural phenomena. And afterwards she was like, oh, hey, that's all I ever wanted. I'm like at the top of the mountain.
我当时在听这个我特别喜欢的TED演讲。就是伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特关于成功的那个。她基本上说，她一辈子都在——她是一位作家——一直在等待成功。她一直在等一本书出版，等一本书成为畅销书。然后她写了《饭祷爱》，大家都知道，这是一个文化现象。之后她说：“噢，嘿，这就是我一直想要的。我站在了山顶。”
Now what? And she had to actually really relearned to love the process. And it's called learned industriousness, which I love. It's like a psychology term that's kind of in opposition to learned helplessness where it's like learned industriousness is about not. being too overly invested in what obviously you care about the outcome but actually you care more about enjoying the process it's kind of like the age or question of like what's better the destination or the journey and this thing this this this idea says no the journey 100% because how you're
“现在干嘛？”她其实必须重新学会去热爱这个过程。这被称为“习得性勤奋”，我非常喜欢这个心理学术语。它有点类似于“习得性无助”，即习得性勤奋不是过分执着于结果——当然你在乎结果——而是你更在乎享受这个过程。这就有点像那个老问题：目的地和旅程，哪个更好？而这个观点给出的答案是：100%是旅程。因为如果你讨厌旅程，你怎么能到达目的地呢？对吧？如果你根本不热爱你正在做的事情，你怎么能坚持熬过那些看不到结果的日子呢？对，说到那些看不到结果的日子。我觉得对于我们在生活中想要实现的任何事情，让人望而生畏的是，很多我们想要达成的目标并不会在一夜之间实现。我觉得这是我们在开始做某事时可能会表现得被动的一个主要原因，因为我们知道我们明天的付出明天并不会看到成效。你知道的，我们需要明天的付出、接下来的每一天以及之后的几个星期，才能真正开始看到成效。我认为这种恐惧或缺乏
meant to get to the destination if you hate the journey right like how are you ever going to care about all that time where you're not going to see results if you don't actually love the thing that you're doing yeah talking about you know all the time that you don't see results. I think with anything we want in our life, it can seem daunting that so many of these things that we might want to achieve are not things that are going to come to us overnight. And I think that's a huge reason we might be passive in starting something because we know that our effort tomorrow is not going to be seen tomorrow. You know, it's going to take our effort tomorrow in the next stay in the weeks after before we really start seeing things. And I think that that fear or that not
即时满足感是我们对事物表现得被动的主要原因。而对于任何伟大的事情，你知道，“坚持就是胜利”虽然是个老生常谈的话语，但我真的觉得它千真万确。因为，你知道，一件事可能需要尝试99次，然后在第100次成功了。但正因为你坚持了那100天并付诸行动，第100次的成功弥补了你之前为了之付出的一切努力。相比之下，你知道，那100天、那100次尝试，无论是什么，反正都会过去。你可以让它们在被动中溜走，从不尝试；或者你可以通过不断尝试、学习、再学习，直到成功，或者只是日复一日地坚持，直到你的成果积累到足够让你真正看到它发生。我是说，
immediate satisfaction is a huge reason why we might be passive in things. And when it comes to anything great, you know, it's so cliche to say consistency is key. But I do think that it really is because, you know, it could take 99 tries at something and then the 100th one works. But because you showed up for those 100 days and you did that, that 100th one being a success makes up for everything else that you've worked for versus, you know, those 100 days, those 100 tries, whatever it is, those are going to go by anyways. And you could have those go by being passive and never trying, or you could have those go by trying and learning and learning until it works or just being consistent over and over until your results compile enough to really see it happen. I mean,
以播客为例，无论是你们的还是我们的，我相信我们双方在真正觉得“哦，这是一期我超级骄傲的节目和话题”或者“哦，天哪，这个传播度真广，它火了”之前，一定都做过很多期节目甚至经历过好几个迭代。所以，没有任何你做的事情会取得即时成功。因此，能够接受并理解这一点——没有什么真正值得拥有的东西会立即成功，或者给你带来即时满足感——我觉得这是克服被动心态非常重要的一步，因为这是你必须要接受的现实
taking podcasts, for example, yours and ours, I'm sure we both had many episodes or even iterations of the podcast and the content before we really felt like we had something like, oh, that was an episode and a topic that I was super proud of, or, oh, wow, that just reached a lot of people, that went viral. Like, it doesn't, nothing that you do is going to be an immediate success. And so being able to accept that and understand that, like, you're going. like nothing worth having really is going to be like an immediate success or give you that immediate gratification, I think is a really big step in not being passive because that is something you have
只有这样，你才能真正投身于你想做的任何事情中。当你思考自己是如何感知时间的时候，这是一件挺酷的事情。至少对我来说，在被动与主动、或者说被动时间与成功创业之间，如果一件事需要一个月的时间，而你因为害怕、觉得需要付出巨大努力、没有精力或者不想承诺而选择不做它。那个月会过去，而且比起你全力以赴的时候，它会过得相当快。但在一个月之后，你会回过头来说：“天哪，我刚刚浪费了
to accept in order to step into the activity of whatever it is you want to do. It is kind of a cool thing when you think about how you perceive time, at least for me, in terms of passive versus active or, you know, passive time versus a successful venture. say something takes like a month and you choose not to do it because it's scary and it's going to take a lot of effort and you don't have the energy or whatever you don't want to commit to it. That month is going to go by and it's going to go by pretty quickly compared to if you're putting the effort in. But then after the month, you're going to look back and say, oh my gosh, I just wasted
这整段生命。如果我当时开始了那件事，我现在会在哪里呢？”对吧。那一个月将会感觉像度日如年。相反，如果你选择在那个月初开始做一件事。它花了一个月左右的时间，在你的眼里它被视为成功了，你为此感到非常高兴，感到骄傲，一切都很顺利。那一个月可能会非常难熬。那一个月的实际工作可能会让你觉得漫长得像个永无止境的世纪。但一旦你达到了那种让你觉得这很成功、感觉很好的阶段。就像我为此感到骄傲。那一个月感觉就像是一夜之间发生的。你会忘记所有即时的艰难时光。就像你有多少次熬夜到深夜，比如像是在跟截止日期赛跑，为了赶出一期节目，或者像你在拼命工作。每个人都有过这样的时刻，无论是学校、工作，还是
this whole life. If I had started that thing, where would I have been? Right. And that one month is going to feel like an eternity. Whereas the opposite, you start something at the beginning of that month. And it takes about a month and then it's in your eyes deemed successful and you feel really good about it and you're proud about it and things are going well. That month may have been grueling. The month itself of work may have felt like an eternity. But once you get to the stage where you're feeling like this is successful, this is feeling good. Like I'm proud of this. The month is going to feel like it happened overnight. Like you're going to forget about all of the immediate hard times. Like how many times have you been up until way like, like, past midnight, like you're fighting a deadline to get an episode in or like you're, you're doing work. Everyone has had times, whether it's school, whether it's work, whether it's
无论什么，你都在过度工作，拼命把事情搞定。然后你提交了任务，大功告成，它感觉很成功。你会想：“我为自己感到骄傲。我做到了。那太棒了，让我们再来一次。这感觉真好。”相反，如果你处于被动区，当然，就努力和付出而言，那是轻松的选择。但当你走到终点，意识到自己没做成什么事时，那种感觉太沮丧了。这就像是一个动量问题，对吧？我觉得这归根结底还是在于你，每个人——这真的是老生常谈。每个人的一天都只有24小时，对吧？被动的人会看着这些时间，心想：好吧，它们是空的。
whatever, you're overworking yourself getting worked on. And then you submit the thing, you're done with the thing, it feels successful. You're like, I'm proud of myself. I did that. That was, let's do it again. Like that's good. Like this feels good. Whereas the opposite, if you were in the passive zone, sure, that's the easy choice in terms of, you know, effort, exertion. But that's so frustrating when you get to the end of it and you realize I didn't do much. It's like a momentum thing, right? And it's like, I think this comes back to the, at the end of the day is you, everyone, this is such a cliche. Everyone has 24 hours in their day, right? The passive person will, I think, look at those hours and be like, okay, they're empty.
所以我就随便用什么填满它们吧。我就这样过，你知道的，我将按小时过日子，按周、按月、按年地生活。然后你最终回顾过去时会想：好吧，但我错过了所有这些真正可以改变某些事情的机会。我有过这么多机会可以在某一天做出一个微小的改变，在接下来的一天做出更大的改变，并为自己看到一条完全不同的道路。而我认为，那些积极选择自己想要的生活的人，看待时间不觉得它是空白的，而是将其视为机会，心想：太棒了，这就是我想做的，这就是我想成为的人，这就是我想努力的方向，比如我想对自己的健康负责，所以有这么多
And so I'll just fill them with whatever. Like, I'm just going, you know, I'm going to do an hour by hour. I'm going to do my life week by week, month by month, year by year. And you just end up looking back and being like, okay, but there was all these opportunities for me to actually change something. There were all these opportunities for me to make a small change one day, a bigger change the next, and see a completely different path for myself. Whereas I think somebody who is like actively choosing what they want for their life sees time, not as space, but as opportunity to be like great like this is what I want to do this is who I want to be this is like what I want to work on this is like I want to do better by my health so like there are all these
时间我可以去锻炼，有这么多时间我可以选择吃更健康的食物，我可以去看医生，照顾好自己，可以拉伸。而消极的人会想：好吧，这是空白时间，如果有空闲，那到时候再说吧。所以我认为这关乎于：是的，这并不完全关乎长期目标，也并不总是关乎过度劳累。并不是总要把每一个小时都用来成为最好的自己，因为最终你会精疲力竭。这关乎于：这就是我对生活的期望。这如何融入我的一天？我可以在哪里为它腾出空间和时间，让它不再是顺其自然，而是我亲手创造的一天？因为你如何选择过
hours in which I can go and exercise and all these hours in which I can like choose to eat better foods in which I can go to the doctor and I can like take care of myself and I can stretch whereas a passive person is like well this is empty space so if that comes up maybe we'll do it so I think it is about being like yes it's not all about long term goals it's not always about overworking yourself. It's not always about using every single hour to be the best version of yourself because eventually you will burn out. It's about being like, this is what I want for my life. Where does this fit into my day? And where can I make space and time for this so that this isn't just whatever happens. This is like a day that I have created. Because like how you choose to live your
每一天，就是你如何度过这一生，对吧？到了最后，在生命的尽头、月末、周末，这一切都归结为这些微小的单位和我们必须做出的微小的决定。这就像是：你所做出的决定，是让你回首时要么A记不起来或者后悔，还是你选择的决定会让你觉得：“我真的很高兴我做了那个决定。我为自己感到骄傲，尽管它很难。”你知道，有时甚至只是改变你的叙事方式以及你对自己说话的方式。我认为，从说“我想成为某种人”转变为“我就是某种人”，这里面有着巨大的力量。即使这是一个巨大的力量。我认为。
days is how you live your life, right? At the end of the like at the end of your life, at the end of your month at the end of the week, like all of that comes down to these small units and these small decisions that we need to make. And it's kind of like, are you choosing the decision that you're going to look back on and either A, not remember or regret, or are you choosing the decision that you're going to be like, I'm really glad I did that. I'm really proud of myself, even if it was hard. You know, sometimes it's even just like changing your narrative and how you speak to yourself. I think there is a huge power in the shift from saying, I want to be something versus I am something. Even if it's a huge power. I think.
这有点像“假装直到你成功”那种类型的事情，你的心态和自信驱动着一切。我认为在我们的节目中，几乎每一个话题，我们都能找到一种方式追溯到你对自己的信念、你与自己的关系，因为这就是区别，比如：哦，我，比如，我想更健康。但那是把它当作一件未来的事情。就像：哦，那是我必须去做的，我总有一天得开始。我必须去实现的目标。而相比之下，说：哦，我很健康，我做健康的抉择。哪怕只是这样说，你就已经完成了50%，因为你仅仅通过说出这句话，就已经跨过了心理上的那道坎。
it's like a fake it till you make it kind of thing your mindset and your self-belief drives everything. And I think that's on our show, that's something that almost every topic, we can find a way to drill back to your belief in yourself, your relationship with yourself, because it's the difference between like, oh, I, like, I want to be healthier. But that is putting it as like a future thing. Like, oh, that's something that I have to, I have to start someday. I have to achieve. versus saying like, oh, I'm healthy, I make healthy choices. Even just saying that now you're like 50% of the way there because you've already gone over the hurdle of your mind just by saying that.
现在你可以做到了。就像说：我很自信。我很健康。我是一个好朋友。我很努力。想想看，这比说“我需要改掉拖延症”要强大多少倍。然后你在告诉自己：哦，那是我以后必须承担的任务，去教
Now you can do it. Like saying like I'm confident. I'm healthy. I'm a good friend. I'm hardworking. Like think about how much more powerful it is instead of saying, oh, I need to stop procrastinating. And then you're telling yourself, oh, that's a task I have to take on in the future is to teach
自己如何停止拖延。然后你就一直停留在那个舒适的被动区，拖延，拖延，再拖延。而相比之下，如果你说：我很努力。我要把这个做好，让自己骄傲。仅仅是叙事方式和说话方式的这种转变，就足以把同样的活动从被动的事情变成主动的事情。所以这又回到了我们本集节目开始时的讨论，这并不意味着我要在生活中增加更多的事情，让生活尽可能地忙碌，而是：我如何活在当下，利用这同样的24小时、同样必须完成的任务、同样的空闲时间，把它变成我自己的东西，而不是任由它
myself how to stop procrastinating. And so then you just stay in that same passive zone, procrastinating, procrastinating, procrastinating. versus being like, I'm hardworking. I'm going to get this done and make myself proud. Like, just that shift of the narrative and the way that you say things is enough to take the same activity and change it from a passive thing to an active thing. So it kind of comes back to how we started this episode, whereas like, it doesn't mean I'm adding more into my life and making it as busy as possible, but it's like, how am I being present in my life and taking these same 24 hours, these same necessary tasks, this same free time, and just making it my own versus letting it
发生在我身上。老实说，这纯粹是一场心理游戏。对。正如你所说，在许多方面，这更多的是心理上的，而不是物质上的。对。对。好了，杰玛，你刚才提到了“势头（momentum）”这个词，我认为这真的非常重要，因为关于在生活中做一件主动的事情所带来的势头，以及它能如何
happen to me. It's such a mental game, honestly. Yeah. As you said, it's mental more than it is material in many ways. Yeah. Yeah. Well, Jemma, you said the word momentum earlier, and that I think is really huge because there's so much to be said about the momentum of doing one active thing in your life and how much
彻底改变你的存在感并改变你所做的其他事情，有很多话可以讲。我想对于每一个想要迈出更为主动的第一步的听众来说，这就是：早上醒来时你能做的第一件事是什么，能让你感觉更积极主动？也许你一骨碌爬起来，立刻看手机，然后被其他所有人的生活和世界所吞噬？也许你能做的第一件事就是把你的双脚——字面意义上——把双脚踩在地上，喝一杯水，或者干脆站起来，把灯打开。
that can completely shift your presence and change everything else you do. I think for everyone listening who wants kind of that first step forward of being more active, it's like, what's one thing that you can do first thing in the morning to make yourself feel more active? Maybe do you roll out of bed and immediately look on your phone and get sucked into everyone else's life and everyone else's world? Maybe the first thing you can do is like put your own, literally like put your own feet on the ground and like drink a glass of water or just stand up and turn your own light on.
做一些能让你感觉自己正在掌控之中的动作。或者，在开始新的一天前你还有一个小时的时间，你可以洗个澡，给自己做顿丰盛的早餐。你可以出去散步。我认为，如果你能在一天开始时做一件让你感到积极的事情，那么在接下来的这一天里，你会感到自信得多，也会觉得活在当下得多。我甚至想到了这一天与那一天的区别，因为——你知道，对我来说每天都有点不同。有时我起床出门，度过了超级高效的一天。有时我睡懒觉，感觉有点懒散。如果我有一天早上睡懒觉、很懒散，没有真正出门，那么我觉得当我终于出门时，我只是在
Like some action that just makes you feel like you're doing something in control. Or maybe you have like an hour before the day and you can take a shower or you can make yourself a good breakfast. You can get out for a walk. I think if you can do one thing in the beginning of the day that makes you feel active, then the rest of your day you're going to feel so much more confident and you're going to feel so much more present in it that like I even think about the difference between a day where because, you know, every day is a little bit different for me. Sometimes I'm up and I'm out of and I have a super productive day. Sometimes I'm sleeping in and I'm feeling kind of lazy. If I'm having a day where I like sleep in and lazy in the morning, don't really get out, then I feel like when I do get out, I'm just kind of like trudging through my day,
机械地走过这一天，打勾完成任务。相比之下，如果我有一天，你知道，我做的第一件事是去户外呼吸新鲜空气，或者做一些对自己有益的事情。那么突然间，我觉得自己，你知道，走在街上就像是我在统治这座城市一样。即使我做的事情和另一天完全一样。如果你能通过在开始时控制生活中的一个小方面来建立一点势头，它真的会给你一种掌控自己生活的感觉。即使你必须为工作、学校或其他任何事情完成任务，它也会让你觉得，你知道，你在掌控它。你不仅仅是在应付它。这就是重点，你在
checking the boxes versus if I have a day where like, you know, the first thing I do is, you know, get some fresh air outside or do something good for me. Then suddenly I'm like, you know, I'm walking down the street feeling like I'm literally running the city. Even if I'm doing the exact same things that I'm doing in the other day. can build a little bit of momentum with taking control of one small aspect of your life in the beginning, it really just gives you this sense of authority over your life. Even if you have boxes you have to check for work or for school or for anything else, it just makes you feel like you know, you're doing it. You're not just getting through it. And that's the thing you're doing
掌控它。这就是你，对吧？听着，这就是我们一直在回归的核心。我觉得在我们快要结束时，这就是这一切的核心。这就是这一切的核心，是你的选择、你的时间、你的决定、你的价值观。这就是核心所在。这关乎于不要为了别人而做事，只为了你自己；不要为了满足别人的期望而做事；不要从你最糟糕的自我或那个你并不真正喜欢的自我出发去
it. This is you, right? Like, that's the thing that we keep coming back to. And I feel like as we kind of like wrap things up, like that's the center of all of this. And it's. And it's the center of all of this. is your choices, your time, your decisions, your values. That's like, that's what it is at its core. It's about not doing things for anybody else but yourself, not doing things for anybody else's expectations, not doing things from the place of kind of your worst self or the self that you don't really like,
做事，而是从最好的你自己和理想中的自我出发去行动。所以我要非常感谢你们两人的到来。我要说欢迎再次回到节目中。这是大家将听到的第一期节目。谢谢你们再次加入我，并一起探讨这个话题。我觉得这是一个非常解放、非常具有启发性和激励性的话题。如果听众想听到更多内容，他们可以在哪里找到你们？对。
doing it from the best version of you and you're like ideal self. So I want to say big thank you to both of you for coming. I'm going to say back on the show. This is the first episode people will be hearing. Thank you for joining me again and for kind of talking through this. I feel like this is such like a very liberating and like inspiring, motivating topic to cover. Where can the listeners find you if they want to hear more? Yeah.
嗯，他们可以在Spotify、Apple或任何你听播客的地方查看我们的节目《Girls with Goals》。我们还有一个Instagram页面叫@Girls with GoalsPod，但我们个人的账号是Carolyn Canine和Catherine Canine。这两个名字在Instagram和TikTok上都能找到。非常感谢再次邀请我们上节目。我们前后录制了好几次，每一次都非常棒。所以这太棒了，我们真的很感激。对，对。
Well, they can check out our show Girls with Goals on Spotify, Apple, wherever you listen to podcasts. We also have an Instagram page at Girls with GoalsPod, but our personal accounts are going to be Carolyn Canine and Catherine Canine. And that's both Instagram, TikTok. Thank you so much for having us on again. We recorded back and forth a few times and every single time has been great. So this is awesome. And we really appreciate it. Yeah, yeah.
我非常喜欢你们对待节目录制的方式，你们总是有那么多很棒、很切合实际的建议，而且对于所有听众来说，这也非常贴心、平易近人。所以我很高兴我们能来这里与你分享这个话题。我认为这是一场双方都受益匪浅的精彩对话。非常感谢。是的，我是它的超级粉丝。所以我会把他们所有的链接都放在本期节目的描述中，这样你们就可以去关注《Girls with Goals》的动态了。
I love the way that you approach your episodes and you always have so much great tangible advice. but it's also very comforting and approachable for everyone who listens. And so I'm glad that we were able to come on and share this topic with you. I think it was a great conversation from both ends. Thank you so much. Yeah, I'm a big fan of it. So I will leave all of their links in the description of this episode so you can go and follow along with what Girls with Goals are doing.
这是一档精彩的节目。我个人非常喜欢。如果你喜欢我们今天讨论的内容，你会在那里发现更多类似的内容。非常感谢大家的收听。请确保在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或任何你收听的地方进行关注。如果你喜欢这期节目，请与朋友分享，或者留下一个五星好评。这确实对节目的成长和触达新听众非常有帮助。一如既往，我们下周再见。
It's an amazing show. I personally really enjoy it. And if you like what we talked about today, you'll find so much more of it there. So thank you so much for listening. Make sure that you're following along on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening. And if you enjoyed this episode, share it with a friend or leave a five-star review. It really does help the show to grow and reach new people. As always, we'll be back next week.
在此之前，注意安全，保持善良，我们很快再聊。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。在1979年，对我来说那是一个大时刻。对大卫来说84年也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着弄清楚我们是如何在
Until then, stay safe, be kind, and we'll talk soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it
我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。那是个疯狂的年代。那是个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《用最难的方式学习》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《用最难的方式学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控使双胞胎怀孕。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest, conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欧文斯女士，这个特定的测试你做了两次，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马伦吉。我的脑子都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
this particular test twice Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and. Michael Marengi. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。输入是TWO%。这是一个IHeart播客，保证是真人制作。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
null